[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag à spécial
élections municipales les français ont
la parole pendant toute la campagne on
va essayer de comprendre quelles sont
vos préoccupations au quotidien avec
bien sûr des reportages sur le terrain
vos remarques et notre sondage sur nos
réseaux sociaux et puis bien sûr notre
débat avec pour thème aujourd'hui
l'ascenseur social en france est-il à
l'arrêt pour en parler nous sommes avec
jean françois amadieu sociologue et
spécialiste des discriminations sociales
face avoue jacques sapir économiste pour
être les france et puis jean marc
sylvestre journaliste spécialiste des
questions économiques également pour
notre chaîne merci d'être avec nous sur
ce plateau en matière d'égalité des
chances
la france est parmi les moins bons
élèves de l' ocde 21e sur 30 il faut en
moyenne six générations ce qui
représente 180 ans pour qu'une personne
n'est au bas de l'échelle sociale
atteignent le niveau moyen un sentiment
d'injustice fortement ressentie
notamment en région paca par exemple à
marseille on pense que l'ascenseur
social est bloqué voyez ce reportage de
nadège ad razak et lucas tu as et on en
parle après pourquoi les inégalités
sociales sont plus marquées dans la cité
phocéenne
marseille c'est près de 900 mille
habitants 39 % des foyers assujettis à
l'impôt communautarisme infrastructures
vieillissantes accès différents à
l'éducation et les raisons de
l'immobilisme sociales sont nombreuses
il ya des portes qui souffre selon le
milieu social le point de vue des gens
déjà l'adresse selon l'adresse que vous
donnez à l'éducation que vous avez eu ou
le métier de vos parents vous êtes
jaillit sur une certaine catégorie de de
travail et d'autres non les moyens
financiers jouent énormément
demain si je vais entrer dans une grande
école de commerce
ce que j'aspire bay je sais que je vais
devoir avant tout ça demander un prêt à
la banque soit travaillé pour me payer
moi mon école de commerce parce que je
sais que mes parents
seront pas forcément dans la capacité de
mener payés tandis que fils d'ouvrier un
fils de quatre sera plus simple pour lui
de d'y accéder quoi il y aura même pas
question de souci d'argent
son seul souci ce sera préparé le
concours comme l'état là où il est
responsable c'est d'avoir enclavé tout
tout tout ces gens dans un même quartier
et attendre que ça passe et attendre que
ça à voir là il a pris maintenant alors
qu'aujourd'hui c'est devenu ingérable
après l'état c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas
non plus tous les torts mais il a ce
temps là d'après un rapport de france
stratégie le régime social d'un individu
joue un rôle capital dans son niveau de
vie un enfant de cadre
ainsi à cinq fois plus de chances d'être
riche qu'un enfant d'ouvrier les écoles
de la ville qui dépend théoriquement de
la ville sont dans un état épouvantable
la ville elle-même a estimé à un
milliard d'euros
la réfection de ces écoles ça veut dire
que rien n'a été fait l'ascenseur social
c'est une fiction c'est un truc
l'oligarchie à inventer pour faire
croire aux pauvres qu'ils avaient une
chance quelconque
non seulement il est pas dans ce sens
social mais a pas d'escalier de services
voyez alors si de temps en temps on en
prend on dit voilà regarder il a réussi
c'est un peu comme le fait qu made man
aux états unis on donne un exemple mais
quand vous les états unis ce que vous
voyez sur tous la misère un ascenseur
social qui est en panne depuis 40 ans il
n'y a même plus d'escaliers de service
pourquoi les français ne croient plus
jean jean françois amadieu déjà ce qui
serait quand on fait des comparaisons
internationales et comprend les sondages
d'opinion sur les sujets qui sont
l'ascenseur social les inégalités la
perception
deux de ces sujets la france est
toujours extrêmement mal classés sur
tous ces sujets alors c'est certainement
le pessimisme des français l'aspect
contestataires mais il est certain que
les ça fait depuis longtemps que les
français sont sans illusion alors
peut-être que des explications aussi
c'est que les français
comment dire à la différence peut-être
d'autres pays on pourrait penser à la
chine à l'inde ou d'autres pays
au fond et même aux états unis c'est
vrai que chez nous les gens
s'accommodent de moins bien de ces
inégalités il est constaté que soit
l'inégalité des chances de la mobilité
sociale ou bien les inégalités de
revenus de patrimoine
elles sont moins bien accepté chez donc
c'est sans doute pour ça aussi qu'il ya
cette sensibilité mais le plus frappant
c'est que malgré cela ça ne change pas
c'est ça qui est le plus intéressant
probablement parce que il n'y a pas de
traduction et de portage politique crois
qu'il faut revenir à ça quand même
depuis déjà assez longtemps de ce sujet
mais j'espère qu'on pourra prendre
quelques exemples c'est ça qui est le
plus frappant non pas que alors que tout
le monde en est parfaitement conscient
c'est une question de ressenti jacques
sapir on l'a vu l'argent le nerf de la
guerre quand on part évidemment avec un
gros handicap en la matière ça il ya peu
de chance finalement d'y arriver en
france ou est ce que c'est un ressenti
qui est un petit peu exagéré alors c'est
un ressenti
et comme tout ressenti il faut pas
considérer qu'ils soient exagérées ou
pas les chiffres
voilà voilà ce qui est intéressante
question c'est de comparer ce ressenti
au chiffre alors qu'est ce qu'on voit
dans les chiffres on voit que
l'ascension sociale c'est plutôt
accéléré dans les années 70 c'est dans
les années 80 mais que depuis la fin des
années 90 elle tend à se ralentir y en a
toujours
en réalité mais il ya aussi et c'est un
phénomène qui est extrêmement important
à fort immobilisé surtout une forte
descente sociale et moi je pense que
psychologiquement
le fait que des gens soient confrontés à
des descentes sociale c'est à dire à des
gens qui perdent leur statut
ça les impressionne d'autant plus de
gens qui redescend il ya plus de gens
qu'il ya plus de gens qui redescendent
que de gens qui montrent d'ailleurs
on le voit que ce soit pour les hommes
que ce soit pour les femmes
bon et donc ça c'est un problème mais en
même temps il ya toujours effectivement
une certaine ascension sociale donc là
vous voyez ça c'est la mobilité sociale
observé des femmes par rapport à la mer
et on voit que aujourd'hui on est à peu
de choses près à l'équivalent ascension
ou descente mais si on regarde d'autres
chiffres par exemple la comparaison
entre les femmes et les hommes
et bien on verra que ce n'est pas
exactement ce type de résultat qu'on a
globalement et loire voilà globale et
enfin voilà alors ça vous avez et vous
voyez que chez les hommes c'est quelque
chose qui est nettement plus marquée que
chez les femmes
donc il y a aussi cet aspect cette
espèce de différence par sexe qui
s'explique alors qu'ils s'expliquent par
de nombreuses choses le fait par exemple
que on le sait dans l'éducation
nationale
les filles sont plus travailleuses que
les garçons c'est tout bête est à
égalité de situation sociale bien sûr
qu'elles auront des problèmes
les filles qui viennent des milieux
populaires mais comme elles sont plus
travailleuses et bien d'une certaine
manière elle s'en sortiront un peu mieux
que les garçons
moi ce qui me frappe le plus dans ces
graphiques c'est le fait que on a eu une
forte ascension sociale je vous dis dans
les années 70 dans les années 80 et au
début des années 90 on a le point le
meilleur en 93 par contre depuis 93
évidemment la situation se détériore
alors ça peut être dû au mauvais
fonctionnement de l'éducation nationale
c'est vrai mais ça peut être dû à
différents autre phénomène est
effectivement désormais le poids de
l'argent commence à peser de manière de
plus en plus importante sur la capacité
d'insertion sociale oui ce qui n'était
pas le cas effectivement puisque en plus
la priorité colle est la même pour tous
et sur l'école est gratuite est censé
être censée être gratuite
alors on va y venir évidemment on va
écouter d'abord emmanuel macron
lorsqu'il parlait justement des dépenses
de l'état pour essayer de dénivelé
ces différences sociales écouter la
politicienne regarder on met un faux nom
d'adam des minima sociaux
les gens ils sont impôts on est sympa
mais on dirait ce pauvre élèves pauvres
ceux qui tombent beau et reste pauvre
on va voir un truc qui permet aux gens
s'en sortir ces trucs par l'éducation ne
peut pas d'entente de combat c'est comme
ça qu'il faut le faire c'est ça qui fait
donc faut prévenir la pauvreté et
responsabiliser les gens pour qu'ils
sortent de la pauvreté
jean marc sylvestre un an on entend le
le coup de gueule emmanuel macron il
devrait y avoir un trou pour s'en sortir
mais alors quel est il selon oui enfin
j'avais oublié le son son coup de gueule
le facteur qui me choque le plus c'est
que c'est vrai que l'ascenseur social
est en panne
peut-être qu'on y reviendra mais je
pense qu'il est en train de repartir
dans certains cas dans certaines régions
les derniers chiffres du chômage
j'espère qu'on va on va en parler son
sont très révélateurs phénomène mission
meilleur pas globalement ils sont
meilleurs ils restent une france d'en
bas à une france d'en haut mais ça n'est
plus un clivage géographique c'est autre
chose et c'était c'est très intéressant
quand on voit les départements qui
décolle et les départements qui qui
reste steiner non il peut être qu'il est
enfin s'améliorer peut-être que la
nouvelle génération des millennials se
comporte différemment avec des besoins
et une demande sociale et une demande de
consommation et une demande de
travailler différente de celle de leurs
aînés avec n'ont pas forcément une
accumulation ou une optimisation de
leurs revenus mais plutôt une
utilisation du capital qui est à leur
disposition et je pense notamment au
développement de toutes les économies
collaboratifs comme le airbnb le blabla
car et tout ça qu'ils sont ne requis
sont rien d'autre qu'une optimisation de
l'utilisation d'un capital qui a été
accumulée par les générations
précédentes parce que les voitures ou
les appartements conception qu'on peut
louer
donc il misé là dessus mais ce que je
voudrais surtout dire et c'est ça qui
est scandaleux et ça nous ramène à la
phrase de demel macron c'est que on est
le pays où l'ascenseur social est
effectivement en panne avec un ressenti
très fort et on est le pays qui dans le
monde et le plus redistributif cmh
sommes nous avons 56% depuis quittant 10
bien sûr en redistribution mais la
redistribution bon sang de bonsoir ça
sert une île ça sert principalement à
essayer de réduire les inégalités
or il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas
bien que ceci ne va pas dans la machine
redistributive
il ya des pertes en ligne il ya des
pertes en ligne et puis il ya un mauvais
procès ce qui fait que que ça vous ça
vous ça vous colle des gens dans une
situation emma l'éducation nationale
c'est vrai l'éducation nationale ne
fonctionne pas et ne remplit pas sa
mission
je je je pense par exemple à une
plateforme sur laquelle fonctionne comme
dans l'autre dans l'éducation nationale
le système de la carte scolaire mais ça
a été une connerie monumentale parce que
ça vous à savannah scotché des gens dans
l'école où il habite alors qu'il aurait
fallu faire circuler les gens pas mal
quand on a un président et moi je me
souviens j'étais de mettre des
universités un peu partout dans l'est
dans les dents dans les départements au
plus près des familles
c'est une bêtise il faut qu' il faut que
les jeunes puissent circuler pour aller
dans une autre région
il aurait mieux valu que ça circule equi
il fallait consacrer l'argent à autre
chose et assurer la mobilité à des cités
universitaires maintenait ces inégalités
dans un livre on a maintenu ces
inégalités et on s'est pas préoccupé de
ce qui a été la véritable cause de la
panne de l'ascenseur social c'est la
capacité de trouver un emploi c'est des
jobs c'est le job qui vous sort de deux
de cette misère sociale et de ce
déclassement social
donc on s'est laissé avoir par par le
déclassement liés à la perte des emplois
industriels
et puis on s'est laissé avoir aussi par
la possibilité de permettre à
l'entreprise d'embaucher plus facilement
la série de réformes qui a été fait
depuis
nous disons françois hollande ou
peut-être un peu avant même même au
moment de la crise par rapport sarkozy à
débloquer la chose les résultats ont
tardé les résultats sont en train
d'apparaître
je trouve que les résultats sont en
train d'apparaître et ils sont quand
même assez spectaculaire dans la mesure
on va arriver à un taux de croissance la
2 8% et sans doute de 7% du pour ça non
thomas sotto match au match et c'était
extrêmement est extrême
imprudents jean-françois de prévisions
alors ça on verra on fait 10 ans fiction
mais j'en étais à 12
non non on n'a pas été à 12 et le
problème c'est qu'on sait très bien que
la le gouvernement confond le taux de
chômage et le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi le nombre de le nombre de
démarches et un nom ils sont
parfaitement content et ça ils sont même
contestées par les gens de l'insee je te
signale on refera un débat urgent sur le
chômage ce sera la thématique d'une de
nos émissions
jean françois amadieu on parler d'eux
est-ce que les inégalités sont aussi
visible selon une cartographie française
précisait ce qu'elles sont l'apanage une
région plus qu'une autre
est ce qu ont pas ou alors est ce qu'on
les trouve dans toutes les zones
géographiques
non je crois que le un des facteurs
effectivement qui peut jouer vous
reveniez dessus c'est la situation des
bassins d'emploi du marché du travail
parce qu'effectivement les taux de
chômage vont exercer un effet on le on
le sait après mais il ya quand même
d'autres facteurs qui jouent sur les
chances de réussite scolaire
par exemple quand vous prenez la région
bretagne traditionnellement l excellent
dans ses performances et on sait que
dans d'autres parties du territoire
national ou de la métro ou d' ou de
l'outre-mer les performances et les
académies peuvent être différentes donc
ça c'est connu il ya cette variable et
même très très forte quand on regarde
les roule la performance de dans le
système éducatif
alors après il faut en faire l'analyse
il ya plus c'est important pour
comprendre aussi la reproduction sociale
plus ou moins importantes et puis les
performances du système éducatif vous
tout à l'heure vous avez un reportage
sur marseille on peut penser à d'autres
zones géographiques alors vous avez à la
fois des territoires dans lesquels il va
y avoir une situation de pauvreté
importante qui se maintient avec des
vous parliez de désindustrialisation ça
c'est des territoires de ce type et puis
vous avez les territoires dans lesquels
il y a eu des flux migratoires très
important et il est évident que lorsque
vous comparez les scores pisa lorsque
vous faites ce type d analyse nous
savons que là ce qui a joué parfois en
aggravant la situation du milieu social
ça pouvait être le fait que vous êtes
enfants issus de l'immigration ou d'une
immigration récente et que des leurres
vos parents n'avaient pas le capital
scolaire
et c'est bien connu qui vous permet dès
la maternelle de plus rapidement de
d'avoir les apprentissages fondamentaux
concrètement votre mère vous lit une
histoire une fois ou deux fois par
semaine et vous lis des livres etc
c'est il faut quand même le rappeler
parce que c'est connu quand on fait des
comparaisons des performances des
systèmes éducatifs c'est un élément
oui mais c'est compliqué d'avoir des
résultats que oui mais parce que
effectivement on sait qu'à résultat
c'est une des variables par exemple on
sait très bien c'était des cris
d'enfants
livre d'hugues lagrange sait très bien
que la taille des fratries est variable
selon les flux migratoires elle a des
effets importants sur la performance des
enfants c'est pour ça que tout ce qui
pouvait ça fait depuis des années que
les spécialistes de l'éducation savent
que pour améliorer éviter la
reproduction sociale et introduire
d'égalité dans ce système outre les
aspects de cartes que vous évoquez
l'autre point important c'est un la
taille des classes et 2 ça va être le
don quelle est la question des fratries
c'est surtout l'accent qui doit être mis
sur le cp
là la maternelle la grande section c'est
à dire le sait ce que l'excellent sûr
mais ce que je veux vous dire c'est que
demandez-vous depuis combien de temps
nous nous faisons depuis combien de
temps il a été décidé de mettre en
oeuvre
là où ça doit être fait c'est à dire le
plus tôt possible en maternelle une
politique qui permet cette égalité des
chances dès le plus jeune âge
parce que moi j'ai connu ça il ya
plusieurs années j'ai monté avec
l'éducation nationale un grand réseau de
280 grandes entreprises françaises
soutenues par l'éducation nationale est
un rêve avec une charte on a fait ça
saoule gilles de robien
c'est le réseau des entreprises au
service de l'égalité des chances très
bien oui non mais c'est très bien mais
moi je me souviens très bien quand j'ai
expliqué aux gens du monde de
l'entreprise aux uns et aux autres je
vous parle de ça il ya quinze ou vingt
ans quand je leur disais mais quand même
il faudrait pas simplement s'intéresser
aux jeunes qui veulent rentrer à
sciences po accéder aux grandes écoles
peut-être qu'on pourrait s'intéresser à
la maternelle les gens me regardent les
hurons c'est pas le sujet et de pub et
c'est en effet depuis jean michel blanc
car hélas qu'on a mis en oeuvre cette
idée contre qui est une évidence
scientifique mais bien connu qui est que
la taille des classes avaient un effet
donc le nombre d'enfants que vous avez
dans une classe c'est quand même basique
et deuxièmement depuis qu'en deuxième
exemple la france dans toutes les
comparaisons de l' ocde
vous le savez que maintenant c'est admis
enfin la demie on le savait déjà et
depuis quand on s'attaque à la question
de la rémunération des enseignants du
primaire
enfin c'est quand même invraisemblable
toutes les études scientifiques faut
être clair toutes les études que nous
avons pas seulement ce que fait l'eau
ces deux mais tout le monde
nous savons très très bien tu as été
fait en angleterre aux états-unis dans
plein de pays que une variable
considérable de la performance du
système éducatif et du fait qui va
corriger les inégalités c'est la
rémunération de l'enseignant c'est
simple c'est seulement regarder depuis
quand on sait à la suite des roquettes
bancaire le savait burger ne l'ignoré
pas mais ils pouvaient pas le faire ça
coûte trop cher met donc fin à ses jours
mais ça ce sont trois facteurs il aurait
mis la relationniste un facteur de
détail attractivité de sa qualité des
gens mais ce n'est pas parce que vous
allez payer les instituteurs nuit deux
fois plus et vont être meilleurs
non surtout pas de rémunération au
mérite ça marche pas dans les conformer
strictement aux il ya moins de gens qui
se présentent que le nombre de places de
la sphère privée
on retrouve aussi la le phénomène de vos
femmes tout à l'heure parce que si les
femmes ont bénéficié de l'assurance de
la censure sociale c'est qu'ils ont pu
accéder non un travail qui était
d'ailleurs moins rémunérés que les
hommes que les hommes ne voulaient plus
et plus que leur mère puisque leur mère
de travail et dont vous faites la
comparaison avec la merde on fait ça
donc voilà c'est ça
mais ce que je voudrais revenir pour
intervenir sur avec avec des petits
exemples qui dit kiki cole est qui et
qui perdure la panne de l'ascenseur
social
les duvalier
il ya bien sûr il ya l'assistance
généralisée ce poids de l'assistance
généralisée n'est pas motivant à partir
du moment où le différentiel entre votre
rôle est d'assister et votre revenu de
travail et production n'est pas assez
bas vous n'avez pas forcément intérêt à
le chercher et c'était tout l'objet des
réformes annoncées n'ont essayé ça
pendant trente ans on a on a perduré
dans ce système là pour des raisons plus
politiques syndicalistes et la deuxième
exemple j'aimerais vous donner c'est
l'éducation nationale vous avez
totalement raison pour donner l'exemple
de la bretagne que je connais bien la
bretagne c'est une des régions les plus
les plus les plus performants en termes
de santé le résultat est une des raisons
pour m'adonner moi c'est que c'est aussi
la région où il ya le plus enseignement
libre d'enseignement catholique et c'est
pas dans l'enseignement catholique qui
produit les qui produit les bacheliers
c'est l'enseignement public pourquoi
parce que vous avez une concurrence
effrénée dans un village entre
l'enseignement libre et d'enseignement
catholique l'enseignement libre attire
naturellement des populations mais
l'enseignement là l'enseignement public
et bien va les attirer par la
performance il donc le facteur
concurrence c'est dans leurs listes de
lecture une la concurrence comme moteur
n'est pas rose la concurrence le moteur
de l'excellence c'est un moteur dont
l'excellent vérité c'est là où il ya une
dimension culturelle
en bretagne on a beaucoup expliqué que
c'est quand même la structure familiale
le rapport à l'éducation la même manière
que si vous réfléchissez pays d'asie
à l'église c'est pas la pardonner
république sédiments rapport à
l'éducation familiale grande famille
bretonne ne met plus leurs enfants à
l'école catholique saint fiacre jeudi un
deuxième facteur c'est cette idée qu'il
fallait favoriser l'accession à la
propriété par exemple donc on a favorisé
l'accession à la propriété
résultat on a scotché des gens dans des
régions on leur dit en les incitant à
devenir propriétaires de leur pavillon
ou leur appartement avec des aides à
n'en plus finir
et puis quand le job est parti eh bien
on est resté coincé au chômage et les
enfants aussi sont restées de la
mobilité c'est la crise la mobilité
c'est la crise et c'est dans tous les
dans tous les cas l éducation c'est pas
votre votre avis jalili mais la mobilité
peut jouer mais on constate aussi par
exemple dans un pays où il ya une très
grande mobilité bien plus grande qu'en
france et même bien plus grand en europe
d'un point de vue général les états unis
lee a malgré tout des problèmes
d'ascension sociale qui sont extrêmement
extrêmement important donc on voit bien
que la mobilité n'est pas une solution
aux dentelles je ne dis pas qu'elle est
mauvaise mais elle n'est pas une
solution
en tant que tel un autre problème que
vous avez dit qu'il me semble
effectivement très important c'est la
maîtrise de la langue de la maîtrise la
maîtrise de la langue est essentielle si
un élève arrive au collège sans
maîtriser la langue et sans maîtriser
les des opérations de base il sera
absolument perdu donc ça ses fruits mais
il faut revenir sur un point qui me
semble important
notre système a produit de l'ascension
sociale
alors d'abord il a produit de
l'ascension sociale globale même si
l'anc est que je citais qui est une
enquête insee ne couvre pas la période
des années 50 on voit très bien que là
il ya une ascension sociale mais qui s
explique aussi par ce que il ya une
génération creuse arrive une génération
qui plus est bon on continue à produire
de l'ascension sociale dont les années
70 80 et le début des années 90 et on
constate qu'à partir de 95 97
le phénomène s'arrête puis s'inverse et
la l'ascension sociale des mines eu donc
je crois qu'il faut vraiment réfléchir
sur ce qui s'est passé à ce moment là
est-ce que ça traduit la volonté de
stratification de la société exprimées
par les gens qui étaient arrivés dans
les années 60 dans les années 70 dans
les années 80 je n'exclus pas le fait
que y est grosso modo une génération qui
fasse un petit peu couvercle de marmites
pour les autres ça c'est un premier
problème
2 effectivement une population qui est
plus hétérogène
alors je ne dis pas que ce soit
nécessairement un problème parce que on
a eu des enfants de l'immigration mais
de la vieille migration des enfants qui
sont nés dans les années 70 voire dans
les années 60 dans des familles qu'ils
ne maîtrisaient pas mieux le français
que les familles bien de dire que je
signale en bretagne que tu as cité
moi j'avais des cas le cas de babel mère
qui vient d'une famille où la langue
vernaculaire c'était pas le français
c'était le breton c'est pour ça que j'ai
ajouté la taille des files occasion les
migrations succinct et l'exode
exactement mais là aussi elles avaient
une sera très importante
elle était dans une famille de six bons
et lll réussi un parcours d'ascension
sociale dans les années 50 60 kg a les
moyens tournage aussi peut-être
alors oui effectivement l'espérance tout
à fait on était dans une situation de
plein emploi
ça a beaucoup joué mais il faut rappeler
ici que parmi les problèmes qui joue le
plus il y à la question de la maîtrise
de la langue et il y à la question de
l'image que renvoie le système scolaire
dans les yeux des parents quand vous
avez des parents qui font confiance dans
le système scolaire
les résultats de l'enfant s'améliore
automatiquement quand vous avez des
parents qui sont en critique face au
système scolaire qui disent que c'est un
système qui c'est greg etc de manière
quasi naturelle elle a été démontré il
ya un fameux livre qui s'appelle
pygmalion à l'école qui montre
l'importance de ces représentations sur
les enfants y compris sur les enfants
très petit puisque là on parle d'enfants
de 4 5 ans dans nos pygmalion à l'école
est bien là vous n'avez pas d'impact
donc il faudrait et c'est exactement la
confiance aussi
faut reconstruire la confiance il faut
reconstruire la confiance d'une partie
de la population française vis-à-vis de
l'école on va on va continuer d'en
parler bien sûr la france championne des
inégalités sociales à travers son
système éducatif
restez avec nous on continue ce débat
donc sur les inégalités en france on se
retrouve dans quelques minutes rester
avec nous
[Musique]
ce qui s'est passé sur tesla si vous
voulez est assez symptomatique du reste
vous avez une déconnexion complète entre
la valeur et le prix si vous prenez la
valorisation boursière c'est à dire on
est monté jusqu'à 165 milliards pour une
boîte qui depuis le début père en cumulé
6 milliards et demi je ne validerai pas
la valorisation actuelle qui est
complètement décorrélé des fondamentaux
en effet mais après il ya tout de même
les aspects dans cette société qui
peuvent être valorisés à une certaine
dans certains montants au delà en tout
cas de deux des voitures en elle même il
y à la technologie du logiciel qui est à
l'intérieur et il ya également les
batteries qui peuvent être vendus ou la
technologie qui peuvent être vendus à
d'autres personnes ils vont 350 mille
voitures
ça veut dire que vous valoriser la
voiture entre 400 et 500 mille dollars
la voiture c'est une manipulation de
cours pur et dur
[Musique]
à
il faudrait que les nations puissent se
regrouper notamment une troisième force
et c'est troisième force et l'europe
mais l'europe est incapable de faire ça
il y à une remise en cause de la
relation très privilégiée entre l'europe
et les étages et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
nous devrions développer un dialogue
france allemagne russie chic tout çà çà
çà çà çà çà paraît pas avancer dans le
bon sens quand même le risque pour nous
c'est de sortir de l'histoire
moi je suis convaincu que l'avenir des
relations internationales pour les 15
ans qui viennent c'est la relation entre
les etats-unis et la chine nous
européens si nous ne sommes pas capables
d'être le troisième pôle à ce moment là
on aura des fragilités et en sortir à
l'histoire
[Musique]
call it mag la suite avec jean françois
amadieu sociologue et spécialiste des
discriminations sociales jacques sapir
économiste pour rt français jean marc
sylvestre journaliste spécialiste des
questions économiques
en france la pauvreté augmenter les
inégalités se creusent alors que le pays
connaît dans le même temps une
croissance inédite depuis 13 ans quelles
en sont les raisons voyez des
explications de notre journaliste dit
marosi et on en débat avec nos invités
en france en 2018 selon l'insee 14 7% de
la population vivait sous le seuil de
pauvreté
en d'autres termes 9 3 millions de
français gagner moins de 1065 euros par
mois un chiffre en hausse de 0,6 point
par rapport à 2010 est pourtant en 2018
la croissance s'établissait à 1,7 pour
cent
cette dernière ne profiterait donc pas à
toutes les catégories de la population
les 20 % de français les plus aisées
détiennent en effet une masse de revenus
4 4 fois supérieure aux 20% les plus
modestes
un écart en légère augmentation en 2018
alors qu'il était stable depuis 2013
cette hausse s'explique en partie par la
forte augmentation de certains revenus
comme les dividendes qui sont
principalement l'apanage des ménages
aisés d'autant qu'au 1er janvier 2018 en
traite en vigueur le prélèvement
forfaitaire unique plus connu sous le
nom de flat tax destinée à alléger
l'impôt sur ce type de revenus autre
explication à cette hausse des
inégalités la baisse des apl les aides
personnalisées au logement pour les
locataires des hlm qui représente
parfois plusieurs dizaines d'euros en
moins pour les ménages qui en
bénéficient à noter cependant que
l'insee ne prend pas en compte dans ses
calculs la baisse des loyers des
logements sociaux censés compenser cette
réduction des apl cela dit même en
retirant la baisse des allocations
logement de l'équation
la tendance reste inchangé il y à bien
également la baisse de la taxe
d'habitation ou encore la bascule des
cotisations chômage vers la csg mais ces
mesures de bénéficie principalement
qu'aux ménages imposables donc au dessus
du seuil de pauvreté
d'autant qu'il ne faudrait pas oublier
que ces chiffres de l'insee ne concerne
que les revenus
oui les inégalités sont encore plus
criante lorsque l'on observe le
patrimoine toujours en 2018 et toujours
selon l'insee les 10% les plus aisés
détenait 720 fois plus de richesses que
les 10% les plus pauvres
en résumé la croissance bénéficie
majoritairement aux ménages aisés
contribuent à creuser les inégalités et
ne permettent pas d'enrayer la pauvreté
voilà donc pour le constat jean marc
sylvestre des pauvres qui seraient de
plus en plus pauvres certains
économistes ne sont pas d'accord et des
riches qui seraient de plus en plus
riches est ce que le gouvernement
finalement on n'a pas une part de
responsabilité non mais je veux bien que
leur et que le gouvernement écoute les
responsabilités alors il est coupable de
tout mais je crois qu'il ya aussi un
comportement un comportement culturel un
comportement individuel aussi il ya des
chiffres qui me frappe
on n'a jamais eu autant d'épargnants que
ce que qu'aujourd'hui depuis 15 ans si
vous prenez le montant des dépôts en
livres et a vu qu'elle faisait pas c'est
considérable
si vous prenez si vous ajoutez à ça les
perles et les les blés plan d'épargné
retraite qui ont été pris avec les
assurances vie qui sont qui sont d été
du déplacement aux basiques à tout cet
argent nous rapporte strictement rien
puisque a pas de taux d'intérêt et c'est
considérable ça représente à peu près 50
à 60 mille euros par français cinquante
à soixante mille euros par française
nous fait le total des encours divisé
par le nombre développe ça ne bloque pas
d'économie saah sah permet ça signifie
quand même que le pouvoir d'achat
distribués et théorisé dans une grande
part notamment celui qui a été distribué
en 2018 et 2000 et 2010 9
il a été thésaurisée pourquoi ça traduit
une méfiance
non pas dans la société une méfiance
dans l'avenir avant c'était de d'épargné
de précaution incertain c'est dans les
pages de précaution donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas de
projets pour ces gens sans aveu dire que
l'on n'a pas de 2,2 des smiths oui c'est
une forme de pessimisme
il y a eu des idées on a vu les
ce qu'a fait le gouvernement jusqu'à
présent 1 qui a creusé aussi ces
inégalités jacques sapir vous est ce
qu'il ya une part de responsablité
néanmoins dans les choix qui ont été
faits par le gouvernement pour le voir
les restes ont pu riches les pauvres
en tout cas la frange la plus pauvre et
plus pauvres alors oui il ya des
responsabilités des gouvernements du dre
pas simplement de ce gouvernement là on
peut l'appliquer aussi au gouvernement
de françois hollande même au
gouvernement de nicolas sarkozy c'est
une longue histoire
alors plusieurs points tout d'abord
comment vous modifier le système des
retraites
et là on est en face d'une modification
à ses global évidemment va provoquer une
angoisse sur l'avenir évidemment vous
pousser les gens à épargner plus donc ça
il faut savoir que c'est de toute
manière tout ce genre de réforme est
profondément anxiogène sauf si elle est
à la fois bien appliqué si elle est bien
maîtrisée par le falher rien faire pour
rien au monde ce qui allait bien gérée
par le gouvernement ce qui vient
maintenant le cac alors que l'autre
l'autre raison de nous emmène dans le
mur le système est non
ils étaient équilibrés tina aussi un
gène on le constate dans la rue
alors ça c'est un premier point l'autre
point qui me semble effectivement très
important et là la responsabilité est
ancienne je me rappelle ce qu'avait dit
nicolas sarkozy
nicolas sarkozy pratiquement la première
année avait dit je vais rétablir
l'autorité des professeurs dans l'école
et on voit la situation
on est arrivé jusqu'à maintenant bon ce
que fait monsieur blanca mais les apl
pour les absents que ce qu'a fait
monsieur blanc caire peut-être très
critiquable sur toute une série de
points mais très vite on le au moins
d'une chose c'est que il a pris
conscience que 1 les salaires des
enseignants se sont dégradées depuis une
vingtaine d'années en particulier avec
le blocage du point de rémunération ça
c'est un point important est que deux
kylie a massivement un problème à la
fois de crédibilité dans le système
scolaire et de rapports entre les
familles et le système scolaire
bon donc ça ça pose évidemment un énorme
problème comment on va le résultat je
pense qu'il faut l'attaquer pas
différent premier c'est un point
troisième point
évidemment la question
du chômage ou plutôt la question de
l'emploi et ce qui est important c'est
le fait que dans les nouveaux emplois
qui sont ouverts bien sûr il ya quelques
emplois bien payés industriel mais on
voit quand même que la masse la grande
marche de ces emplois ce sont des
emplois de service assez mal pays et
donc là d'une certaine manière
l'offre est en particulier l'offre
incrémentale d'emploi s'avère aussi
traduire cette espèce de blocage de
l'ensemble de la société
oui je suis pas sûr que la la la la
qualité des emplois qui sont offertes
aujourd'hui sur le marché soit aussi
dégradée que que que tu le dis elles
sont c'est ce sont évidemment des des
emplois de service puisque nous sommes
dans une société de services
donc on va pas inventer des emplois
industriels du bois on va pas le faire
en quelques mois
mais ces emplois de service ils peuvent
être assez sophistiqué mais il nécessite
pour pouvoir être géré beaucoup de
formations et beaucoup d'adaptations
d'emploi aujourd'hui
mais si vous avez énormément de secteurs
qui ne trouvent des services à la
personne qui nous avait ça la personne
mais des services de restauration le
général jcfa s'est passé gras dans les
services à la personne en tant que ce
soit c'est quand même quelque chose de
transparent
mais ce n'est pas qualifié et bien il
sait malgré la concurrence va faire en
sorte et les besoins vont faire en sorte
que l'on revalorisera vraisemblablement
ses emplois ce que je constate quand
même c'est que depuis un an on a créé
beaucoup d'emplois dans ce pays et c'est
le facteur principal ce sont des actes
loi qui permette d'évoluer aussi mais ça
charles il vaut mieux avoir un emploi
même à l'emploi un emploi modeste que
pas d'emploi du tout enfin quelle est la
situation sociale culturelle et humaine
du type chitika pas de job qui se lèvent
le matin spaghetti qu'il sait pas quoi
faire alors est-ce que la france fermait
on va écouter emmanuel macron parce
qu'il ya quelque chose d'intéressant
quand on pousse en chariot est ce qu'on
peut devenir propriétaire de son
commerce vous avez la réponse
pourquoi vous demander dans les classes
moyennes françaises
vous voulez quoi pour vos enfants il ya
dix ans était fonctionnaire c'est moins
vrai maintenant ils veulent faire
entrepreneurs où ils veulent faire école
de commerce ou ingénieur
parce que le patron de la boîte oui
travail fait
a fait cette école là pourquoi en
allemagne on met les enfants en
apprentissage parce que le dirigeant de
l'entreprise il a fait un apprentissage
les gens du bon sens et donc il est
important aussi de construire dans
l'entreprise des carrières d'excellence
qui passe par l'apprentissage qui
reconnaissent la valeur de
l'apprentissage et qui permet aussi de
montrer que c'est une filière
d'excellence dans notre économie
voilà donc ça ce sont des vieilles
habitudes françaises à la filière
d'excellence et ce que si il faut casser
ce modèle oui alors ça reste extrêmement
vrai et d'ailleurs l'amélioration du
marché du travail qui en est fait ses
preuves et stern ont mal est pas
contestable à fait évidente devrait bien
aider ce qu'il faut dire c'est quelqu'un
qui a pas de croissance
oui bien sûr mais quand ils avaient leur
propre terre d amélioration va prendre
un exemple
classiquement là nous continuons à vivre
en france avec ce schéma dans lequel les
bons emplois dans les grandes
entreprises bien rémunérer les emplois
de cadres en particulier vont être
occupés par des jeunes sortis du système
éducatif c'était comme le président le
rappelait en effet ces sorties d'écoles
d'ingénieurs la cobla droit à l'erreur
non plus comment un système éducatif en
france ce que je veux dire c'est que on
continue à valoriser ce type de
formation il n'y a pas on a toujours du
mal en france à avoir des mouvements de
deux promotions internes permettant de
devenir cadre un jour quand on ne
l'était pas avant
on a toujours peiné en france à le faire
et encore aujourd'hui c'est vrai à
chaque fois vous avez une nous on voit
bien nos étudiants aujourd'hui sont le
trouve tout de suite un emploi dans
l'enseignement supérieur dans
l'enseignement supérieur dans à ce
niveau de formation c'est plus simple
mais qu'il ya quelques années mais donc
ça c'était un point qui est très
important
que je voulais simplement supprimé c'est
cette annonce après pardonnez moi c'est
vrai que vous avez une primauté à aux
diplômés et à la filière d'excellence
mais c'est à la grande entreprise
c'est un bon résultat allez allez à la
roche-sur-yon en vendée où vous avez que
des petites et moyennes entreprises
c'est l'un des départements il n'y a
pratiquement pas de chômage allait en
auvergne a les seins j'ai pris là un run
alpes a les mêmes en mayenne tenait en
mayenne il ya à peu près 2 à 3% de
chômage sa surface frictionnel changer
d'emploi s'est passé pas des gens qui
sortent de l'ena d' hec ou d'ailleurs ou
2 ou 2 ou d'une école d'ingénieur ils
ont fait toute leur carrière sur le
terrain de golf
soit ils sont faites dit c'est technique
10 et d'apprentissage et l'école
apprentis ou bts
beaucoup de gens sont issus du bts dans
une petite entreprise de mécanique
petites entreprises textiles non ne fout
pas faux pas ou la france non mais là on
a on a un blocage on va prendre deux
trois exemples parce que les choses se
sont même dégradée j'ai déjà fait les
enquêtes sur les 300 premiers dirigeants
d'entreprises françaises et vous
regardez d'où ils viennent sur les 250
premiers vous devez en avoir un ou deux
qui a inquiété fils d'ouvrier mairie qui
nous pas davantage à l'assemblée
nationale nous n'avons jamais eu une
assemblée nationale aussi caricaturale
de ce point de vue il ya la france
insoumise une aide soignante je crois
c'est tout si vous voulez on est de ce
point de vue il ya vraiment un blocage
tout à fait non ce sont des habitudes
qu'on a prise depuis longtemps vous avez
rien je dois donner dans les entreprises
mais également dans l'ensemble alors
évidemment les grandes entreprises mais
également dans la sphère politique dont
beaucoup de temps ici ici boulet dans
les élites pour parler clair où
effectivement ça va passer par
certains nombre de comédies de titres de
noblesse ou de formation de type de
formation mais avec des parcours bien
défini mais ça c'est vraiment très peu
ouvert alors je voudrais dire que
souvent c'est un point quand même joué
je voudrais signaler que on parle sans
arrêt depuis des années à l'agenda
politique de faire une place aux femmes
dans des conseils d'administration dans
la vie politique ou à des personnes qui
sont issus de l'immigration cela on en
parle énormément on regarde à chaque
fois comment est composé un gouvernement
combien sur l'hélice politique il ya
d'hommes et de femmes combien il y a
deux dans les conseils d'administration
et moi je faisais remarquer il ya déjà
bien longtemps avant qu'on les modifier
que dans les conseils d'administration
par exemple où on introduisait des
quotas de genre ou une femme eh bien on
introduisait pas d'obligation il y a
quelques années qu'il y ait des
représentants du personnel comme on le
fait dans d'autres pays
et quant à se demander s'il y a des
enfants d'ouvriers ou des ouvriers dans
un conseil d'administration où dans un
board on se pose pas la question non
plus est déjà calé représentants des
salariés
ça permet d'avoir une représentation de
gens moins qualifiés dans des conseils
d'administration
donc le modèle allemand bosch candidats
sur la présence de travailleurs dans les
conseils c'est une manière d'ouvrir à
d'autres milieux sociaux qui en france
n'existe pas et pour finir il ya un
point je voudrais le dire parce que je
n'a un jour il faudra que ça change
la france a aussi cette particularité
que il y à une convention de l'oit et de
1959 qui s'applique dans tous les pays
dont la france mais l'organisation du
travail qui prévoit convention ses 100
ans qui prévoit que dans le domaine du
travail l'origine sociale c'est à dire
la profession des parents votre origine
sociale est un motif de discrimination
même titre que la couleur de peau le
sexe ou autre chose c'est dans les
conventions internationales depuis la
nuit des temps
enfin au moins pas mal d'années vous
allez sur le site du défenseur des
droits
et vous regardez si origine sociale est
mentionné quelque part vous verrez
jamais jamais c'est n'est ni repris dans
la définition des critères de
discriminations en france serviront pas
traiter ça ne il n'ya jamais d'en quête
sur ce sujet
donc on en parle dans le domaine
éducatif je vais être clair quand on
parle de dean égalité des chances à
l'école
là on se demande si quelle est la
profession des parents bien sûr
quand vous êtes sorti de sciences po ou
de votre vos études quelle qu'elle soit
et que vous rentrez dans une entreprise
et bien sachez qu'à partir de ce moment
là plus personne ne s'intéresse du jour
où vous avez candidate et quelque part
on ne sait plus si vous êtes un enfant
le cas où un enfant 2 or system bord en
revanche on sait que vous êtes du réseau
achètent ces voix là c'est dire que
c'est un réseau science et pirro ça
c'est que nous savons c'est pire que ça
c'est que le téléphone va marcher et 50%
des emplois aujourd'hui quand même le
dire dans là dedans la mouette quasiment
la moitié des cas mais c'est vrai aussi
dans d'autres pays a battu à présent
commendation celle des recommandations
donc si vous voulez et pour les stages
c'est comme ça et nous on fait des gens
qu'elle est moins vrai actuellement
parce qu'il ya une demande très forte
oui également ses frais les traiter ça
mais ça c'est parce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est quand même effarant et à
côté de ça on va vous parler non mais je
pense qu'à ça me fait rire à côté de ça
on va vous parler de forme très
importante de discrimination qui sont là
que des canadiens personne très gentil
non mais c'est une blague comment il ya
un décalage entre le discours et est ce
qu'on devrait faire
il ya des sujets importants et lascif et
l'alim égalité des chances en réserve et
sociales et massive à côté oui mais
c'est parce qu'on se préoccupe de sujets
qui sont anecdotiques et ça descend ça
dépend beaucoup des entreprises et des
chefs d'entreprise moi je connais
quelques entreprises au cac 40 qui ont
parfaitement conscience de cela
interrogé monsieur à s'interroger est-ce
que vous et claude bébéar quand il a
constitué axa rose oui c'est vrai mais
aussi avec celui qui se passe chez
l'oréal a regardé ce match il est parti
heureusement depuis que bébert est parti
sa nouvelle drh et pas du tout parce que
80% de là malheureusement du groupe et
internationales alors donc il faut aussi
faire de la recherche j'aimerais qu'on
parle je voudrais juste une question sur
la formation obligatoire justement qui a
été introduite par ce nouveau
gouvernement la formation obligatoire
pour les jeunes décrocheurs scolaires de
16 à 18 ans beaucoup de jeunes quittent
l'école à 16 ans
le gouvernement veut les inciter à à
suivre des formations justement on en
vient à l'apprentissage qui évoque
emmanuel macron voilà des formations
pour essayer dé remettre sur le sur les
rails du marché du travail est ce que
c'est la bonne méthode selon vous est ce
qu'il ya des mécanismes d'accompagnement
pour essayer de la loi suit alors une
énormité qui va permettre à jacques
sapir
j'ai dit non seulement que c'est la
bonne méthode non seulement il faut que
ça va rendre obligatoire mais il faut
conditionner les aides sociales que l'on
peut percevoir en contrepartie de d'une
formation dont je pense que le type qui
bénéficient d'une formation aidées par
l'état il peut en contrepartie et
l'accès à la formation est ce que c'est
flore du genre je dirais que ça
l'apparence d'une bonne méthode
mais tant qu' on n'aura pas à redonner
une confiance dans de la famille ou de
l'enfant fin de de l'adolescent ou du
post adolescent qui est décrocheurs dans
le système je suis désolé ça ne
fonctionnera pas il faut d'abord se
poser
la véritable question qui est celle de
savoir pourquoi est ce que cet
adolescent at il des crochets on ne
décroche pas pour rien nicolas est perçu
comme une contrainte qui exactement
et si vous voulez faire c'est comme
s'ils voulaient ça c'est la grande
différence par exemple quand vous allez
dans un pays asiatique
quand vous allez encore et quand vous
allez à singapour vous rendez compte
très vite qu'il y a toujours cette idée
qui peut d'ailleurs être je ne dirais
pas fausse mais qui peut être enjolivé
que l'on va réussir par l'école et ça
c'est une forme de prophétie
auto-réalisatrice le plus les gens y
croient le plus ça se produit
inversement quand vous êtes dans une
situation vous d'hydra de toutes les
manières
ces visuels sert à rien c'est fichu
d'avant et bien ça va provoquer d'autant
plus d'échecs de décrochage donc il y à
la séquelle que s'ils voulaient c'est
difficile à maîtriser parce que on est
dans l'immatériel
on est dans de la représentation mais
tant que l'on n'aura pas il voit son
père au chômage depuis qu'il est né
sa mère également au chômage il vit dans
une cité avec que des gosses qui ont des
parents au chômage comment voulez vous
qu'ils s'en sortent alors s'il ya des
cas il ya des cailloux gaza passe par le
travail
non non bien reconstitué un déficit de
20 cas et si vous lui en est plusieurs
ou où ces gens qui étaient dans cette
situation très difficile avec une mère
femme de ménage cinq enfants si l'enfant
mais cette mère qui pourtant pouvait
être analphabète très souvent elles
disaient c'est par l'école que tu
réussiras monsieur et si tu ne vas pas à
l'école tu aura affaire à moi donc c'est
aussi une question de deux milieux
familial jean françois amadieu ces
notions d'éducation
oui c'est un rapport à aux diplômes à la
réussite c'est à dire est ce que la
réussite c'est connu depuis très
longtemps est ce que vous pensez ce que
les parents ou les enfants pensent que
la réussite c'est une question de chance
oui
ou est ce que c'est une question de
l'éducation et d'efforts et de travail
d'efforts d'autre part est-ce que vous
pensez que donc on peut arriver sans
travailler parce qu'on a un talent un
génie ou de la chance ou pas et les
études qu'on a notamment y en a beaucoup
récemment qui sont menées dans plusieurs
pays et formeront évidemment la syrie
aux états unis etc montrent que la
question n'est pas une question ethno
raciales du tout une question de travail
et on s'est aperçu avec des études
précise que c'est simplement la quantité
de travail ce qui d'ailleurs est un peu
inquiétant les américains sont assez
ennuyé parce que les collégiens
américains postes de moins en moins bon
bref certains clubs de vacances
mais si vous voulez ce qui ce qui se
passe que qu'est-ce qui est valorisé
dans notre société a pâti au moment où
vous trouverez votre enseignant
finalement aidé un peu démonétisé bon
rien il est il n'a pas tellement réussi
il compte plus trop vous même vous
constatez que finalement aujourd'hui les
mal formés aussi il est mal formés et
envoyés dans des classes qu'ils ne
maîtrisent pas voilà mais ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est quels sont les
modèles de réussite
depuis quelques années les appartements
vous explique pas tout vous expliquer la
réussite la réussite bas de faire une
télé réalité être un influenceur
finalement un coup d'état de modèles et
quand vous voyez les gains générés en
effet dans des tas d'activités vous
dites mais effectivement pourquoi
s'embêter à travailler ces exercices de
maths à la maison ou faire des devoirs
ou s'ennuyer alors qu'il ya d'autres
moyens et qu'on peut y arriver autrement
et en fait c'est aussi la mise en scène
de ses formes de réussite si si si si
c'est ça la queue qui sont les moyens de
réussir pourquoi en effet faire
autrement donc c'est un ensemble
et là on sait très bien que
malheureusement depuis plusieurs années
les choses se dégradent et il faut
ajouter que bien entendu parce qu'on est
déjà confronté à ça aujourd'hui la
internet
et les réseaux sociaux ont
considérablement modifié les choses bien
sûr les écrans etc etc et ça ça ne joue
pas dans la bonne direction est
donc c'est assez inquiétant toujours
question politique qui nous reste plus
beaucoup de temps question politique la
panne était la faute aussi des
politiques on l'a vu déconnecté on a
accusé emmanuel macron d'être le
président des riches
il ya toute cette sémantique aussi
politique la france qui se lève tôt de
nicolas sarkozy laissant dont avec
françois hollande
cette image finalement que les
politiques renvoie aux personnes qui ont
plus de mal pour réussir ce mets salés
mais les bleus mais aussi pauline les
politiques payent leur démagogie qui a
consisté le plus souvent à acheter des
voix acheter des voix par des promesses
par un certain nombre de choses c'est
comme ça qu'on est devenu le pays le
plus dépensier en matière de dépenses
publiques et sociales et c'est aussi
pourquoi devenu le pays le plus
inégalitaire
je sais trouver plutôt sympathique tout
à l'heure en indiquant que le président
de la république premier ministre
actuellement ne portait pas de
responsabilité particulière dans les
cars 2 de situation entre les entre les
plus riches et les plus pauvres là quand
même une évidence qu'en version
contestera c'est que la politique a été
plutôt fiscalement avantageuses des
retours ceux qui étaient les plus
favorisés ce qui n'est pas contestable
n'a été que de rattrapage et des
entreprises d'investissement et donc
vous voyez la firme a dit et on peut
discuter de la finalité d'efficacité
était aussi le pays qui paient le plus
voilà mémé sur le résultat que ça
produit et sur le fait que c'est en
effet là imputable dort très clairement
à nos choix qui ont été faits à partir
de 2017 c'est certain ça ça c'est
certain maintenant qu'après ça puisse
produire des effets vertueux ou pas ça
c'est une autre discussion sur les
scellés fermés seulement mais ça on le
verra presse du virage qui est un régal
la baisse du chômage
oui tout à fait mais je pense qu'il faut
rappeler que c'est quand même quelque
chose qui se joue sur la longue durée
bien sûr que le gouvernement edouard
philippe a sa part de responsabilité
c'est pour ça mais les autres
gouvernements sous des gouvernements de
ces quinze dernières années ont une
innovation car en tant que cet ascenseur
social en tout cas et non c'est vrai
j'ai eu des déjeuners jusqu'au milieu
des années 80 dit sur mon avis surtout
une amélioration des normes élevées et
ses deux plus délicate à rentrer ça fait
25 ans que la musique est incompétent
c'est le choc total d'internautes
politique envoyé un des candidats
enfin il est plus candidat mais un des
candidats à la mairie de paris qui offre
100 mille euros pour acheter un
appartement baïla bloquer le marché
immobilier
et il a fait en sorte de documentaire
ah non j'ai pas parlé on est dans une
tout va bien on va passer aux questions
réponses est le résultat de notre
sondage en ligne
[Musique]
l'ascenseur social s'est il arrêté à la
naissance à l'école à l'université à
l'entrée dans la vie professionnelle et
peut-être même à la retraite
on a posé la question sur nos réseaux
sociaux et vous voyez le résultat à la
majorité les sondés disent que ce
station soeur sociale s'arrête à la
naissance
donc on voit bien ce ce pessimisme
finalement est-ce qu'on peut s'en sortir
vous avez la réponse à ça résume un
petit peu ce qu'on a dit j'accepte alors
le problème c'est que très souvent
l'école dépend de la naissance si vous
si vous connaissez vous venez d'une
famille dans un bon quartier qui n'a pas
non mais surtout qui n'a pas confiance
dans l'école
c'est ça qui n'a pas un bon ça jouera un
rôle important sur le l'effet de l'école
pour vous discriminés merci beaucoup en
tout cas d'avoir répondu et participer à
ce débat sur rt france c'est la fin de
cette émission rester avec nous
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui pousse tout ça